we got a voicemail yesterday at our
voicemail number a two one nine to david
p which was from someone claiming to be
furious about our pseudoscience
miniseries and then you know from the
first second you hear this person it had
a sort of anti-semitic tinge to it and
by the end of it they devolve into
full-on anti-semitism take a listen hey
david after listening to your
pseudoscience crap turns out you're just
a pill pusher probably getting kickbacks
from the doctors and the pharmacists you
know you gotta find a mystique
deficiency don't take women's our lives
because that's pseudoscience no you
sprained your ankle don't use ice that's
pseudoscience no it's not
you got a obesity problem you can't
control it with with diet and exercise
that pseudoscience no it's not you know
you want everybody to run to the doctor
and get a prescription pills pills no ID
that's all you worried about
enjoy your fifty pieces of silver you
traitor Judas ah there it is my fifty
pieces of silver you traitor Judas why
do you think that this is eight
primarily pseudoscience pusher who is
also anti-semitic or is this someone
who's anti-semitic who's just looking
for something to criticize me with like
is it merrily do you have to be mutually
exclusive no well I assume that it's one
that triggers the other like people
aren't usually fifty-fifty anti-semitic
and pseudoscience pushers it's usually
it was an uneven mix I think the
anti-semitism is in the background and
that I only came out at the end
interesting this is also a classic
example of the straw man fallacy and yes
right push that word around all the time
yeah this is it right they he is taking
down argument I never made and using
them to criticize me we have a great
bonus show for you today I'm out of time
to tell you what's on it but it's a good
one and I hope to see you there